this stuff is creepy and it is insane
clearest clearest portrayal of this from
the la unified schools
la unified schools has a video out to
promote their new policies for how
they're going to reopen
after covid now we know from the science
capital s trademark over the e we know
from the science
that there is no medical reason for the
schools to remain closed the kids don't
really transmit it very much
the teachers and faculty are not at any
particularly higher risk of getting the
virus
the reason that the schools are
remaining closed is because corrupt
left-wing teacher unions are too lazy
and they want to get a paycheck for
doing nothing so
la schools now are pushing how are we
going to reopen this
tell me this isn't the creepiest thing
you've ever heard there's never been
anything like this virus in our lifetime
often it's hard to see the effects it's
having on our children
has this conversation taken place in
your home
mom i'm scared about going back to
school i don't want to get sick
and i don't want to get you and dad sick
our scientists tell us there are three
things we must do to stay
safe wear masks make sure we social
distance
and wash our hands and now your school
with the help of microsoft corporation
has created another
introducing daily pass your exclusive
ticket for safely going back to school
each week you can schedule your free
on-campus covent test
the results are displayed in your daily
pass and if you choose to take your test
off campus
you can post the results in your daily
pass and the moment vaccinations are
available you'll simply be able to
schedule yours through your daily pass
but the real magic is your daily health
check just answer a few simple health
questions every day
and like magic your entrance ticket
appears
it's so wonderful just give us access to
all of your medical data
and i don't know send us some of your
blood too and then
then we can all go back to school and
give us all your rights and
don't have any privacy anymore does this
ever happen in your home
hey mom i'm really afraid of coronavirus
and i
i'm so afraid of going to school no that
doesn't happen because kids don't feel
that way because kids are at
practically zero risk of this virus and
they all want to go back to school
and their rates of depression anxiety
suicide among
kids has been going up because of these
psycho politicians
and the technocrat in tyrants and lab
coats like dr fauci
who are screwing up their lives over
nothing but a power grab
that's what's going on not that creepy
video it gets somehow somehow
it's even creepier by the end so how did
it go
dad i have to admit i was scared at
first but then i felt so safe
it was so good to be back thanks for
keeping me safe
i love you so much
[Music]
what if you're gonna push this kind of
creepy propaganda
can't you it i don't know get better
dialogue dialogue that doesn't send a
chill up our spine thank you
bill gates i mean daddy thank you dr
fauci oh daddy daddy keep meaning to say
daddy
can i call him daddy fauci daddy daddy
dr fauci
uh no this does not represent the
situation
that we find ourselves in and it doesn't
represent the situation we want that's
the kind of radicalism that is being
pushed not by the fringes that's being
pushed
by the liberal establishment we need to
head them off and stop them every chance
we get if it's by
shooting down a nominee to some office
in the government
if it's through elections if it's
through civil disobedience on our own
in prudent cases such as
going back living our lives seeing our
families taking off that dumb mask
make sense to me i'm michael knows this
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
freedom if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video